- So we have time for one
last story to end this hour.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
There's nothing worse at
a white elephant party
than when you've got the exact
gift you want in your hands
and some jerk takes it.
They choose to take it
from you. That is not cool.
That's how a Louisville dental
office treatment coordinator
was feeling when a colleague snatched up
her $25 T.J. Maxx gift
card out of her hands
during a holiday work gathering.
But it turns out there
was nothing to fret about
because she ended up with
the best gift of the bunch.
Just look at her reaction.
(woman screaming)
- That was my present.
- [Woman] Oh my God.
- You can steal it three
times and I take it back.
(audience cheering)
- It has allowed her to do
great things for others.
Everybody, we have her on the
line to explain everything.
Say hi to Lori watching on WDIV-TV.
What's up, Lori?
- Hi, Kelly. How are you?
- I am so good.
Okay, so a colleague took your gift card,
but what did you end up with?
- She took my gift card
and I love T.J. Maxx,
but I ended up taking
some lottery tickets.
In that, she gave me a lucky quarter
and all the girls in the
office started screaming,
"Scratch them off!"
And so as I started scratching
all of those lottery tickets,
I actually hit on every one of them.
It was amazing.
The last one was the $10 lottery ticket,
and as I scratched off the numbers first,
I already felt like this weird feeling.
Two numbers, my number two and number 14.
Number two is my husband's birthday,
and the 14th was when
my daughter was born.
So as I started scratching off and seeing,
like the first one was 20,000,
the second one was 20,000,
I was like, "Oh my gosh."
In the second row, I won on all of my,
on the 14, on my daughter's birthday.
And that ticket ended
up winning me $175,000.
(audience cheering)
- What in the?
I love your photo.
(laughs) That's amazing.
So you're doing a lot more
with this money, right?
- I am.
When they asked me that first time,
I said I was gonna pay off
my daughter's student loans.
But when you get home
and you think about it
and you pray about it, and
I looked over at my husband
and I said, "I've always
been so passionate
about working in dentistry
and I love Dr. Harmon."
And I decided that I was gonna open up
a nonprofit organization
called "Smiles Once More".
It should be up and running in the spring.
And I am hoping to change some lives
because not everyone has the ability
to be able to afford
dentistry, and they struggle.
And your smile is everything.
It's how you get a job.
It's, you know, who we are.
And I just wanna be able to
help some people that need help.
(audience clapping)
- What a great person.
I'm so glad you ended
up with those tickets.
Thank you so much, Lori.
I'm liking your post right now.
- [Lori] Thank you.
- And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those
selflessly helping others just like you.
So they're gonna give you
$1,000. You won again.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my God.
Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- That means a lot.
- Thank you, Lori.
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Utkarsh Ambudkar, Kathleen
Madigan, Dr. Ian Saunders,
Mariana Hostway, Priscilla
Casper, Latoya Edwards,
and all our friends at NBC10 Boston.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.